el s eduardo enríquez editor jefe de la
prensa de nicaragua periodista de autor
de muerte de una república eduardo buen
día buena mañana de miércoles gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 también nos
acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo rosa
pérez masdéu la encargada de nuestra
sección de revista de prensa rosa buenos
días
el guardo quisiera pues empezar a
preguntándole por la situación actual de
la prensa ya pues la mayoría de los
trabajadores están en el exilio esta
persecución política de ortega digamos
un poco el contexto actual de toda la
situación del diario y como la viven
ustedes
y en muchas gracias buenos días gracias
por la invitación raúl y rosa y en la
actualidad estamos viviendo luego de 23
semanas e inició esta
tercera ola de represión de la última
etapa de la dictadura en la cual nos
obligaron a salir de nicaragua y en
estas últimas tres semanas pasamos a
raíz del arresto de dos de nuestros
colaboradores
empezamos a sacar a las personas de
nicaragua a nuestros editores nuestros
fotógrafos nuestros redactores es porque
simplemente no se podía seguir
trabajando en el país
aún dentro de las limitaciones que nos
habían impuesto antes que esa salida que
se da a raíz del 6 de julio cuando son
detenidos dos de nuestros colaboradores
y son allanadas los allanados los
hogares de otros tres de nuestros
colaboradores es una una redactora un
fotógrafo y nuestra administradora de
redacción en este momento estamos en un
proceso de reorganización y estamos
fuera de nicaragua muchos
reorganizándose en costa ricas y
estamos en ese proceso pero hemos
continuado informando no hemos detenido
una información en nuestro sitio web en
ningún momento y enríquez disculpe
precisamente cómo llevan a cabo este
trabajo de informar sobre lo que sucede
en nicaragua desde fuera de nicaragua
así como bien mencionaron ustedes la
prensa tiene 95 años de existencia y
tenemos un personal aunque ya es muy
pequeño en comparación a lo que dijo
hacer en sus mejores momentos y si es
muy experimentado
paradójicamente el tema de la pandemia
que nos obligó a trabajar
a distancia y hacer nuestro trabajo
sigue estar en los lugares donde ocurría
la noticia generalmente nos ha permitido
de desarrollar un sistema de trabajo en
el cual podemos encontrar la información
como como bien dije a distancia
igualmente obviamente todos estos
avances tecnológicos nos permiten tener
acceso a nuestras fuentes y hay mucha
mucha colaboración de la ciudadanía en
cuanto a enviar información que luego
nosotros corroboramos y producto de la
cual profundizado eduardo también le
quiero preguntar sobre las instalaciones
de la prensa en nicaragua teniendo en
cuenta que pues están ocupadas por las
autoridades y poder pues funcionarios
del régimen de daniel ortega qué va a
pasar con sus instalaciones allá en
nicaragua y si están digamos en un
proceso legal por decirlo de alguna
manera para poder recuperarlas
en nicaragua no existen los procesos
legales están como los entiende
un país donde existe un gobierno
democráticamente electo el el 14 el 13
de agosto del año
pasado la policía simplemente se tomó
las instalaciones de nuestro rotativo y
desde entonces nos expulsaron al
personal que se encontraba en ese
momento en el rostro activo detuvieron a
nuestro gerente general bueno de néstor
colman que está por cumplir un año
porque pues desde ese día fue detenido y
no han entregado no han devuelto las
instalaciones no hay manera de tener
acceso a información sobre ellas cuando
lo hicieron el juicio con lorenzo
declararon que las instalaciones
continuarían intervenidas pero no se
habló en ningún momento de una
complicación pero lo que hay es una
complicación de esto
no existe ninguna razón por la cual este
este toma valor este día justo de lavado
de dinero que ha sido el delito favorito
por el cual señalarlo ademán de traición
a la patria por el puente señalar a los
más de
40 personas que han sido arrestadas
desde finales de mayo del 2021
hasta la fecha y el quienes se suman a
unos 150 presos políticos que ya
existían desde las protestas de 2018
pero no existe posibilidad con lorenzo
no ha tenido ni siquiera posibilidad de
ver a un abogado y fue condenado sin
tener esa posibilidad y ha visto
escasamente a su familia en ocho
ocasiones y precisamente qué perspectiva
tienen ante el encarcelamiento del señor
hoffman y también de que de poder
reanudar su trabajo periodístico con
normalidad mientras ortega y murillo
continúen en el poder
y regresar a la normalidad
con ortega y murillo en el poder en este
momento se ve bastante complicado ortega
y murillo son parte común yo no lo llamo
ya ni siquiera el gobierno todo el mundo
está claro de que las elecciones de 2021
fueron una farsa ellos usurpan el poder
y simplemente ya lo ha dicho ortega el
19 de julio recién pasado
lo había dicho antes que no iba a
dialogar con la oposición y bueno como
él en su cabeza que mantiene que su
verdadero enemigo de eeuu dice que
tampoco va a dialogar con eeuu entonces
no hay ninguna posibilidad del momento
que nosotros veamos de diálogo ni de
apertura seguiremos como medio que es lo
que toca es que nos guiando y revelando
los abusos de la victoria y disculpe
señor enrique como antes veíamos la
señora la vicepresidenta rosario murillo
ella trabajó en a la prensa durante
prácticamente diez años como secretaria
del director como se explica en esta
hostilidad frente a este medio a la
familia chamorro en la en la actualidad
qué es una situación
que nicaragua llama llama mucho la
atención para afuera de nicaragua llaman
planos de atención a ella ella fue parte
de la prensa tuvo una relación incluso
muy cordial durante ese periodo e
incluso después la madre de juan lorenzo
holman por ejemplo narraba como cuando
esos países en los año 70 y que ella
también era primera dama en aquel
entonces la señora murillo asistió a la
vela de su esposo sin embargo las
situaciones no se el poder cambiarse a
la gente y se ha convertido en una
persona completamente inaccesible y
completamente dura